does being touch starved affect your
sleep it certainly affects mine i love
to be cuddled as a medical condition
probably not though i've been reading my
comment section you guys have had some
good questions let's get to it
laney shea why do my sunburns never turn
into tans because sunburn shouldn't be
happening to you
shade spf what's probably happening is
you're actually burning your skin and
then that superficial layer ends up
peeling off because there's so much
damage there and your body perhaps
doesn't form enough melanocytes that's
what gives the skin color the melon and
the pigment to your skin and you may not
be a person who has that much melon in
your body that's okay wear that spf stay
in the shade maria turtle
maria turtu riello maria turturiello
maria turturilla
turturiello maria tertiuriello hi mike
what is the difference between a family
doctor and a pediatrician well a family
doctor is able to treat patients of all
ages whether they're one or a hundred
one pediatrician solely focuses on
children both are capable of taking care
of kids i see patients who are part of
the pediatric population all the time
vaccination visits school physicals
complaints developmental delays you know
sometimes we need to get specialists on
board but that would be the same with a
pediatrician because at the end of the
day we're generalists and specialists
are specialists the lannister lion can
giving cpr without a certificate have
legal consequences well i think it very
state by state but generally speaking
the good samaritan rule should apply
that means if you're the only individual
and you don't have a certificate you can
try and save that person's life because
the last thing we want are people being
afraid to help victims so i urge you if
someone collapses call for help right
away and if they're unconscious not
breathing you don't feel a pulse get
those chest compressions going remember
to the tune of staying alive that's all
i'm going to say because i don't want to
get demonetized
royal twilight i was wondering about the
phrase banks open on tuesdays folks and
what it meant when you shoot against the
backboard of a basketball hoop that's
called a bank shot when you play horse a
game where you try to match your
opponent's shot you got to call
or backboard before you shoot if you're
going to use the backboard and your
opponent has to match yourself with the
backboard so for me because i'm nice
with it and i take a fade away and hit
the backboard i go banks open on
tuesdays folks because it's true there
and about the financial system you know
stevens is eating food after it falls
onto a non-sanitized surface bad for
your health chronically are we talking
about the five second rule because i
think bacteria when they see something
fall they're like chill chill chill five
seconds we gotta relax not true it's
already gonna have bacteria is that the
end of the world
is it something i recommend probably not
even my friends who are doctors do some
absolutely atrocious stuff like drop a
piece of chocolate on the hospital floor
and then pick it up and eat and quote
the five second rule please don't ever
do that do you know what's in the
hospitals multi-drug resistant organisms
you do not want one of those hanging
around in your mouth that's right i said
mouth francesca simi why is it that when
you take a bad fall you feel nauseous
and need to throw up well first of all
it could be that you got motion sick
from how heavy you took that fall second
if you fell so hard that you have a
fracture you could also get nauseous
that's one of the hallmark signs of
having a fracture i remember when i was
on that bunny slope on that snowboard
and i thought i was
sean white i fell i learned my lesson
because i got nauseous because i broke
my arm my wrist do we have a dr mike
discord well yes we do although it is
invite only if you sign up to the
patreon for only ten dollars a month but
that money is not for me it's not for
dan it's not for sam and it's not for
bear it's for any good cause that we
decide together at the end of the month
every single month so join now link
below lonely jasonist are doctors
trained to notice signs of emotional
abuse absolutely not just emotional
abuse physical abuse elder abuse and
child abuse as well for example if i
have a very young patient that's coming
in for multiple fractures if we do a
bone scan and we see fractures that are
different stages of healing that makes
us wonder why is this child frequently
getting these injuries plenty of
children like to be wild and run around
and fall and trip it's part of life that
being said if it's consistently
happening could be a sign of physical
abuse or neglect which is another type
of abuse that's equally as important to
notice
now elder abuse is something that's less
talked about but also very very
important there exist individuals who
are being kept alive being neglected
being taken advantage of for perhaps
financial gain for example many elder
individuals will receive social security
government checks retirement checks and
some family members really in a horrible
way will try and take that money away
from them and instead of use it to give
them care they pocket and use it for
their own purposes it's really evil and
when it happens it's devastating and we
need the courts to step in rick cheese
does chocolate really cause acne first
of all rick cheese great username to ask
about chocolate i thought you'd be
asking me about cheese i don't think we
have proof that chocolate directly
causes acne also i don't think it's ever
the case that a single ingredient or a
single food can cause a problem that's
as complex as acne in general when we
looked at research in the past what
we've seen is those who eat a high
amount of chocolate and this isn't just
cacao chocolate dark chocolate this is
chocolate with dairy with sugar with a
lot of high refined carbs in their
caramel all this stuff they were more
likely to get acne now look those people
also led more on healthy lifestyles they
didn't sleep enough they had high stress
levels so it's no surprise that they had
more experience with acne that being
said there have been some small
randomized controlled studies showing
that chocolate can have an effect here
and there but to villainize a specific
nutrient like that i just don't think we
have enough evidence what's really smart
to do if you have acne is to talk to
your dermatologist about all the things
that can be contributing to acne and
then narrow it down from there very
rarely it's gonna be due to a single
food like chocolate like if a patient
walks in and they have very bad acne and
they tell me all the things that are
going on in their life i can't expect
that if i'm just gonna tell them i'll
cut out chocolate you'll be fine it's
not gonna be good medical advice there
have been some smaller studies that
confirmed that chocolate has
pro-inflammatory effects that means
effects that create inflammation in your
skin that can be something that can
contribute to acne second we've seen
high glycemic load diets that means you
eat a specific food it spikes your
insulin that's considered a high
glycemic load that can sometimes cause
an increase in sebum production leading
to acne sebums that oil your skin
creates and eventually or potentially
can block off pores but again there's no
direct tie-in that if you eat dark
chocolate that you will then experience
acne i think it's more complex than that
and simplifying it to food x causing
disease why
don't have the evidence for it lacy
morris have you ever been in a situation
where you had to feel a patient's
abdomen but they had ptsd
no i would say the closest thing that
i've had happen was i had to perform omt
which is osteopathic manipulative
therapy on someone who
was
i guess traumatized in the sexual sense
and part of what i do because they were
experiencing neck pain was evaluating
the neck and i really just went about it
as forthcoming as i could be meaning
giving all the details of what i was
about to do before i did it that
developed a layer of trust with that
patient and we just took it slowly one
step at a time and that sort of
desensitization really helped that
patient a lot as we had more encounters
and we're able to get rid of her neck
pain and she's doing quite well now so
one key is sleeping at night healthier
than sleeping during the day for example
if you work night shift or third shift
does it simply depend on how many hours
you sleep at once when we look back at
evidence meaning look back at
individuals who live the life of
sleeping during the day as opposed to at
night we compare them to those who sleep
at night and work during the day we see
better outcomes for those who sleep
properly at night matching our human
circadian rhythm that being said we
don't have great reasoning for why this
happens outside that it doesn't follow
your natural circadian rhythm and likely
that because of weekends and everything
else you're going to be shifting back
and forth and that's really unhealthy my
recommendation if i was giving it to one
of my family members would be to try and
find a career where they can sleep at
night and work during the day but i know
that's not feasible for everybody i
don't want you to worry about it as if
it's just this horrible thing just know
that is one potential risk factor that
you can mitigate diamond on demand i'm
nearing 18 years ugh midlife should i
start watching for my eating diabetes is
common in half my family line you should
absolutely start looking at what you're
eating now rather than waiting till
later i'll explain why when we think
about heart disease meaning people that
get heart attacks their blood vessels
start getting blocked off from plaque
buildup within the arteries within the
blood vessels but that plaque doesn't
form when you're 40 or when you're 30. i
mean it builds up during those ages but
it really starts laying the foundation
at your age at 18. so if you can live a
healthy life and watch what you eat
early on that's going to pay dividends
when you're in your 30s 40s 50s 60s 70s
80s 90s hundreds hundreds tens or 120s i
want you to be the longest living person
on earth check out these videos here on
the truth about picking your nose or
cracking your knuckles arthritis
stay happy and healthy
[Music]